molten lava fiery destruction and
breathtaking beauty at the same time
these photos capture the moment when a
volcano erupts they were taken by
Icelandic photographer Ragnar Sigrid son
to go acos and photographing an eruption
afternoon rush but then it's also pushes
you to the limit create creatively you
have to be very creative you have to be
on your toes he loves it when a volcano
comes to life he gets as close as
possible whether with his SUV or a small
plane I've been very close I've been you
know centimeters away from glowing lava
but it's moving very slowly and it's a
safe distance of course I've been very
scared I've had to run really fast
mostly because I'm scared but because
things happening but you know pee run
first and Anita
ragnar first rose to fame through his
photos of Iceland's most famous volcano
the Ioffe yacht layer cut the ash it
produced when it erupted in 2010
grounded flights across Europe
Ragnar took 10,000 photos at the volcano
waiting waiting waiting two things for
things to happen to see the eruption
itself because it's 40 now to read it up
of the clouds at under 1000 and you got
the ash and everything everywhere but
you can't see the fire
oh just stay there 24 hours and if or
something
for more than 30 years now Ragnar
Sigurdsson has been photographing
landscapes and nature motifs all over
the far north from Greenland and Norway
to the North Pole
[Music]
but few places have as many natural
wonders as is native Iceland
known as the land of Fire and Ice it's
130 volcanoes and hot geysers of shape
Iceland's national identity it's an
addiction kind of just I think the whole
nation is like that we all love
eruptions as far as as long it's not
taters
I mean sometimes it can be very
dangerous
can't be life-threatening but we have
been blessed the past decades we only
have had kind of what you call tourist
directions a photo shoot at a crater
landscape near Reykjavik it was created
by a volcanic eruption thousands of
years ago capturing images of the
volcanic rock under different light
conditions fascinates Ragnar Sigurdsson
he's always aiming to try out new
technologies and techniques using a
drone he experiments with unusual
perspectives he says he's always on the
hunt for the next killer shot and
there's always another day
another light another situation another
perspective another way to do it or wish
you never it's never done rodner
sigurðsson remains true to his favorite
subject
the next volcanic eruption in Iceland is
sure to come possibly with just a few
minutes notice
[Music]